[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
your money your mental health and even
relationships
that's right my name is anthony o'neill
also joining me today
is uh one of my favorites dr the
dr john deloney both ramsey
personalities here
who are passionate about helping you um
and helping you reach your goals
around life money mental stuff you name
it um
dr john did only host the doctor john
delonly show
and i am the host of the table with
anthony o'neil you can find us on
youtube and podcast
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's called a number
we're here to accept your phone calls
and
dr john and i we pretty much talk about
anything yeah there's not a lot that
goes by that yeah we won't get into so
let's do it
we love talking about anything and
everything but before
before we uh jump on to the phone calls
um we're going to talk to mike in new
jersey uh we're coming right to you
there mike
um i want to talk about where dave is
dave is dave
chris hogan rachel cruz um are joining
craig rochelle tonight uh tonight being
tuesday night january 12th at 7 00 p.m
uh for a free reset live stream event to
kick
off your money goals for 2021.
they're going to give you the motivation
and guidance you need to hit the
reset button and say goodbye to the
money stress for good
so america do me a favor i want you to
text right now stop what you're doing
pull over the car
and text this word reset r-e-s-e-t
to 3-3-7-8-9 right now to sign up and
take the first step toward
lasting financial peace or you can sign
up at daveramsey.com forward slash
reset and check this out if you're in
the oklahoma area and if you want to be
a part of the very limited
live audience it's very very limited uh
go to daveramsey.com for
events and there may be some tickets
available i'm not sure surely they're
sold out by now yeah i'm pretty sure
they are but i mean hey it doesn't hurt
maybe one or two became available
but for the rest of us around the world
listen
2020 was hard yep okay i don't want to
get to the phone calls but i want to be
real here
2020 was hard
and one thing i've learned every now and
then you have to reset
every time every now and then i turn off
my cell phone as a matter of fact let me
turn it off right now before
our producer gets on it uh you know as a
matter of fact make sure my computer
audio is up yeah
so every now and then i have to turn off
my phone and reset it so he can
just stop and then crank back up and
have a fresh breath there fresh whatever
and i feel like this is what this event
is well anthony
i'll one-up you on that i did that
and then the first three or four days of
2021 were like yeah
sunsets yeah we had a beautiful snow
here yes this was going to be 2021 yeah
and then the dumpster fire turned over
and caught the whole
estate on fire and so
this is about money but this is i know
chris personally i know rachel
personally i know dave personally i know
craig
this is gonna be a this will be bigger
than just your money yes
it is this is there was no magic all
right everything's okay once the
calendar flipped over yeah
this was millions of people are still
hurting millions of people are
struggling
millions of people trying to figure it
out and those who have it all right are
still going
what's going on oh absolutely and so we
have over 200
000 people have already signed up for
this it's free yes
watch this thing set down tonight you're
gonna watch some stupid show anyway
right or you're gonna fill your head
with whatever nonsense what on
ever news platform you watch turn that
crap off turn it off
hit reset to three three seven eight
nine watch three three seven eight nine
get your young kids your old kids get
your husband or what everybody your
girlfriend boy for everybody in the room
yes watch this thing tonight listen if
you're on baby step number two
i give you permission tonight to order
pizza
order pizza and get in front of
the tv and reset your entire family
and i always tell everybody don't get
your families there on a screen it's
gonna ruin everybody's brain
tonight get around the screen tonight
get around a screen
pizza i'll even go with the pizza thing
you're all gonna have gas tomorrow
morning when you wake up but it's gonna
be worth it three three seven eight nine
text reset don't miss this event man
don't miss it y'all as a matter of fact
we're going to help mike reset mike
what's going on man how can
dr d and i help how are you guys happy
new year happy new year to you man
how can we serve um i'm 34.
i am single not married no kids um
i make a good salary
at 1 25 1 30. this is a great salary
mike
oh okay mike you may not be single too
long after this call
i own a townhouse i've been here for
about four years i don't know how long
i'm going to stay here
so my question is is it worth paying
down the debt if you don't plan on
staying here
or fully fund more retirement i have
deferred comp with my job and i have a
fully funded walk
it is with my age is it worth doing baby
steps four and six at the same time
or do a little maybe more or the less i
mean i have a lot of money floating
around
i don't really know should i do more
retirement funding like i said because
of my age
are you doing 15 right now right
yeah just about 15. maybe just yeah here
yeah
well i would definitely go ahead and max
out the full 15. okay bottom line just
going ahead and just start investing 15
um and then uh baby steps four five six
and seven we do all at the same time
and so let's say for an example if you
know you're going to be moving in the
next two years
um then yeah you don't really have to
focus on paying down the house like that
no not at all but let's say if you know
you're going to be there for a while
and you want to be in that house then
absolutely especially if you want to
keep the house you know
as far as i'm renting out down the road
to create an extra general
i'm an extra stream of income so i think
right now
the general question on you is where are
you going in your future
and how does this house play a role in
your future
so if you want to pay it off early
please do if you're saying hey i may
only be here for two years
i'm not going to tell you to stress
paying off this house early if you know
you're going to be moving in the next
year two years three years
so step back and ask yourself where am i
going what am i doing
but i would definitely make sure that
you are maxing out your 15
you are a young man you're younger than
me you're single
you're making 125 130 a year owning a
home
yay well here's my other question i'm
going to be phasing out the walk soon
should i start a traditional ira or do
the back door i like to get something
else going
because of your income yeah because of
the income i would definitely recommend
sitting down with a smart vested pro
because we definitely have to go through
the back door roth
um but there are a lot of different
things you can do which i would
definitely recommend sitting out with a
smart vested pro who can teach you how
to properly do these things
uh legally so that way your money is
covered but i have to use the back door
because of my income as well so that's
what i highly highly recommend man but
you're doing amazing stuff mike i mean
there's not too many 34 year old
brothers
that's right you know what i'm saying
single no debt got money
investing own a home you know ladies
what did they say i think his dms are
open i don't know i don't know i don't
know
you know but here's to mike's point i
hear
these two things more more common than
any other thing
hey guys we just bought our forever home
this one came out of my mouth this is
our forever home
yeah we're gonna live here forever yeah
three years we were out yeah
and i don't know how long i'm going to
be here i'm just you know
and then you blink and then it's 15
years you've been living in that house
and you should have paid it off right
right and so either have a plan
absolutely i got two years and here's
what i'm gonna do
yeah or man crush that house chris
you're gonna snap your fingers are gonna
be five years
crush it but then you're gonna have a
paid off house listen if you want
motivation on
how to crush your financial goals i want
you to text reset
r-e-s-e-t to 33789 because tonight
we have some amazing people gonna teach
you how to do it we'll be right back
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at chministries.org
[Music]
[Music]
825-5225 this is the dave ramsey show
and uh i'm joined by the one and only dr
john
deloney my name is anthony ramsey
personalities and we are excited to
talk to you about your life your money
uh your
relationship so please do give us a
phone call
and we'll talk about anything you know
um we don't run away from the hard stuff
we actually run to them i love having
hard conversations
uh jordan is in raleigh north carolina
jordan good afternoon how can dr d and i
help
hey thanks for taking my call guys
ah thanks man
yeah yeah go ahead what's up okay sorry
um so basically i have
a vehicle that i have leased um i'm
about halfway through it
i've looked into getting rid of it the
dealership
said that i could turn it in and they'd
give me forty
thousand dollars but i would still be
responsible for another six thousand
dollars on top of that
i was wondering i have the six thousand
dollars to pay the difference
but i have not had the time to save up
more money to buy
a vehicle with cash to kind of get me
through
um and get out of debt quicker so i was
wondering
what should i do should i continue to
make the payment
set aside more money to um save and then
at the end of the
lease just walk away from it and then i
would have money to i would have that
money that i saved up to
buy a new vehicle for cash or should i
just turn it in
eat the six thousand dollars and i don't
know get a loan for a smaller
payment vehicle i don't know i'm kind of
lost
okay so walk me through this process
again how how much longer do you have on
the lease
i have uh two years 24 months you got 24
months
all right and
how much are you paying a month for the
lease right now uh 560 dollars
60 dollars okay we got 24 months 560
dollars
what other kind of debt do you have
jordan um i
i stupidly bought some solar systems for
my uh for my
house as well so i think that's right
around twenty four thousand dollars
24k and uh roof all right
all right cool beans and then explain to
me the six thousand dollars you're going
to go over on your mouse
is that what i'm guessing and hearing
correctly
no no so um basically they're saying if
i was to go and turn in
my vehicle today um they would only give
me 40 for it but they're saying i owe
about 46 on it
okay okay all right i got you and so if
you did turn in this vehicle today
what would you have another vehicle to
drive
no do you have any cash i do yes how
much cash do you have
i have ten thousand dollars all right so
you can do that
then you have 24k in debt on your roof
now is that 24k rolled into your
mortgage payment
or are you paying that outside of your
mortgage payment i'm paying
outside my mortgage payment okay cool
and you have no other debt outside of
this and at least correct
correct yeah i'm going to turn in the
lease
okay and so here's what i would
recommend uh not recommend i would
suggest you
suggest she has two options you can turn
in at least and i'll have a problem with
you maybe taking out a personal loan for
six thousand
um dollars so you can go down cheaper
okay so your debt is going to go down to
six thousand dollars on the car and
that's
that's fine or you can take that ten
thousand dollars
and go in ahead and just pay off that
six thousand and you have four thousand
uh you keep a thousand in your emergency
fund and put the three thousand dollars
towards that 24k on your roof
all right so if i was you i'm going
that way i'm taking that ten thousand
i'm gonna leave one thousand in there
i'm gonna take six of that ten thousand
um and put it inside of
uh to pay off my lease and then i'm
gonna take three thousand dollars but
actually you're gonna need a vehicle go
by
yeah and i'll take three thousand
dollars and go buy a cash car
and then start attacking the twenty four
thousand dollars on your roof
now because the lease man i just you're
wasting money and you're throwing away
money
and then if you go over your mouse
you're gonna end up paying
more than the six thousand dollars today
so that's what i recommend
and there's something that will be
beautiful in your soul about driving a 2
000
1997 corolla up to your house that's got
25 000
with the solar panels on it i'm a huge
solar fan don't get me wrong
but there's something that's going to be
in your soul that's going to remind you
every day don't ever
ever do this again right right
yeah yeah that's kind of what the point
that's where i'm at now
um i guess maybe i should also mention
it
it's my wife's vehicle and i have a
vehicle however she
can't i mean like my vehicle is a 2002
jeep grand cherokee and
it's too big and we have another kid on
the way so
i have two thousand dollar vehicle for
her to drive i'm just a bit weary
with with that but i mean i would have
to put more stress
on her and i and our relationship so
what's
what's more stress racking up a bunch of
debt and paying a lot of money
or getting a quality used vehicle
temporarily while you save up cash to
buy another one
i think that's something you got that's
something you got to ask yourself
and man you you gave yourself anthony
says this a lot you've got to have a a
hardcore driving why you've got one man
you got another kid on the way
work like crazy pick up a second and a
third and a fourth and a ninth and a
tenth job your goal now is to get your
wife into a safe
safe good used car asap no excuses no
stopping no pausing
get that done man get that done and make
it happen that's a why if i've ever
heard one
yeah absolutely cody is in kentucky uh
good afternoon cody how can
dr d and i serve hey guys how are you
doing today
doing well man how about yourself uh
doing well i found y'all
on youtube oh ramsay about two weeks ago
i've been uh watching a lot of the
youtube videos and um
i am cody cody we're the best looking
of the bunch is that fair
uh yeah that's fair enough excellent i
like where we're headed
all right go ahead i'm 30 i'm 31 and my
dad's been in uh he's uh he owns his own
business he's a
bricklayer by trade he's uh he's been
doing it for 45 years so i've been
helping him the last nine years of it
so the money is pretty good there my
question is i'm kind of tight
on my money and i've got a little bit
saved up but i'm in a little
bet situation as well i love cars i love
bikes so uh it got me in a little bit of
trouble i have a hellcat
um uh oh 41 000 on it
that's not a little bit of trouble cody
that's a big lot of trouble yeah
and i've got a and i've got a harley
davidson
that i owe um 12 000 on
and then the only other debt because i
tackled all my credit card debts um
two months ago tackled those off and the
only one i owe is i owe a lowes for my
washer and dryer at fifteen hundred
dollars
uh now what i was going to say is the
dilemma that i have here is that uh
my dad and i in the winter time as we're
outside
you know when it's a little cold
sometimes we can't work
but as far as money-wise i usually
average around four thousand dollars in
income
a month that's what i get okay
so what am i trying to say here
with tackling should i just go with a
debt snowball or
um or how would i do that because i've
been watching about the debt snowball
and usually tackle the lease to the
highest
as far as money situation i'm not really
struggling
the part is i have twenty thousand
dollars saved up right now in my bank
account but i don't know what to do with
it
i'm nervous when it gets down to that
low part like when it goes
it makes me all nervous so with me just
making them payments it kind of makes me
feel safe because i got that money there
but i know that's not going to help me
in the long run
great so yeah so that's what i was
trying to figure out
what i should do and let me tell you
this cody
nothing extraordinary happens within
size people's comfort zone
so i get it you're comfortable making
the monthly payments
but i truly believe our dreams and our
goals
die within our comfort zone i need you
to step outside of that
i need you to take the twenty thousand
dollars pay that only fifty four
thousand five hundred dollars
that's going to take you down to thirty
four thousand five hundred you're making
4k
a month so i mean i'll go ahead and
start attacking it don't cheat the
system
okay that's what i tell new people all
the
time do not cheat the system line up all
your debt from smallest
all the way over to largest and then you
just attack it that way
now try to figure out how you can get a
little bit more money coming in how can
you turn that 4 into 6k
so you can start attacking your debt a
lot more but
i understand yeah it's easy it's easy to
make the small
minimum payments because you have this
money in the count
but you know what what's what is easy
today
it's hard tomorrow that means you may
have to sell that hellcat brother
yes yeah i didn't want to say that 48
grand against a 45 000
payment brother hellcats goes today
goodbye i'm
selling that joker yesterday that
doesn't even make sense
this is
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
so
america i want you to join us tonight
tuesday january 12th at 7 p.m for our
free
reset live stream event to kickstart
your money goals for 2021
my mentor and boss man dave ramsey will
be joined by chris hogan rachel cruz and
one of my
favorite communicators and preachers in
the world craig rochelle
they'll give you the motivation and
guidance you need
to hit the reset button and say goodbye
to money stress for good
do me a favor actually not me a favor do
yourself a favor do your family
a favor do your grandchildren a favor
oh you have a legacy on them absolutely
text the word reset
r-e-s-e-t to 3-3-7-8-9
uh right now to sign up and to take the
first step towards
lasting financial peace or you can sign
up at daveramsey.com forward slash reset
now if you're in the oklahoma area
tonight and you want to join the live
and in-person audience which i don't i
don't know if there's
too many seats available um but it's on
my piece of paper to say it and it's
only twenty dollars go to daveramsey.com
for slash
events um and see if there are some
tickets available but i'm gonna tell you
right now
um i am gonna be uh in front of
uh my uh computer tonight learning from
the best
uh my mentor rachel cruz and our family
so text the word reset r-e-s-e-t
to three three seven eight nine uh to
sign up and take the first step towards
lasting financial
peace can we be real for a second sure
if you are listening to this
you're not doing anything tonight you're
not
you're gonna go home if you're even
allowed to leave your house
you're gonna go home you're gonna talk
to your spouse
you're going to pet your dog if you're
by yourself
you're going to look at your fish just
swimming laps
and then you're going to text a buddy
and be like hey what what
episodes are we binging or you're going
to get your controllers and your cool
little
headset out and by cool i mean not cool
headset out and you're going to play
video games with your buddies from
college because y'all can't let it go
or partridge in a pear tree you're going
gonna not be doing anything
why how do i know that because the whole
world's still shut down
and so i i i don't like people sitting
around as a family in front of screens
tonight's the night i don't like people
eating pizza and nachos tonight's the
night
it's free
and you can start with your kids you can
start with you you can get
restarted you can re-inject your life
with some hope
re-inject your life with some positivity
and not just kumbaya
look at this everybody the sun's going
to come out twirl not that
that but also a plan for how to get on
the same page with your
with your with your spouse your
boyfriend your girlfriend your job
your money yeah get it done
reset 33789 it would be stupid not to
it's all i'm saying
a couple a hundred thousand people have
already signed up for it to knucklehead
to not do it
do it do it do it man andrew's with us
and uh texas texas actually houston
texas
what's up andrew how y'all doing doing
well man about yourself how can we help
all right so i am 21 years old i just
graduated from texas a m university
and oh no i'm starting my career
with texas dps um with hopes of being a
texas state trooper and so unfortunately
i graduated with thirty thousand dollars
in student loans okay
and um but fortunately i do have a
unique situation of having
six months of um basically no
expenses um while i'm at this academy
because you click there they feed you
and they also pay you and so
i was wondering do i throw basically all
that money
towards my loans and try to graduate
this academy debt-free
or close to debt-free or do i need to
set aside some money
so that when i move i'm probably most
likely gonna be stationed somewhere
um out of houston and so
i'm just not sure if i need to basically
try to pay off all my loans right now or
set aside some money when i have to move
as well
so we're we're in an interesting
situation you know you're graduating you
got you gotta
pretty pretty soon you gotta start
paying this thirty thousand but right
now you're going to police school and
you gotta cash flow that how much is
your police school
no they pay him they're gonna pay him so
he's saying i have no bills for six
months when you go to dps school they
house you they
take you to austin they pay for
everything okay and they give you a
salary
so he could be dumping this off be debt
free how much are they going to pay you
i have about 4 800 a month during the
academy and then it goes up to 5 000 for
the next six months
okay all right all right that's all you
have is the thirty thousand dollars
yes sir all right and they're gonna
stick you you're gonna be in el paso for
a year right are they gonna stick you in
amarillo for a year before you start
applying to other places yeah
and then will they will they make sure
that you stay within texas yeah
yeah okay cool so then great yeah man
put that towards your debt
because here's here's why i also say
that you're not gonna buy a house in el
paso right more than likely right you're
not in my house in amarillo
yeah and so you're gonna just get an
apartment there anyway so you don't need
to have a big pile of cash
right not to put down on the house i
agree i would rather you
graduate this program 100 debt free with
only a thousand dollars in your bank
account
that thousand dollars will help you get
to where wherever they they
uh put you at you really only need a and
here's the truth
let's say if you get down towards the
last two months and let's say you know
exactly where you're going you may need
a first and the last deposit for your
apartment
i don't have a problem with you pausing
um going hard hard on your
own your student loan debt to going
ahead and get your living situation
um up and going but right now put
everything you possibly can
to get out of that and then the last two
months of you and that program
and you know where you're going okay
slow down make sure that your living
situation is is good
then after that once you get back and
you need to complete paying off your
debt which i don't think you will need
to
uh then aggressively go back after it
but man i'm happy for you right here man
this is a great opportunity take
advantage of it
make the wise decision all right andrew
absolutely thank you so much
congratulations on getting academy
that's a hard thing to do
absolutely go do good work and and do
good in the world man absolutely
aaron's with us in fresno california
good afternoon aaron how can uh
dr dni help okay we lost aaron going out
to uh
tampa we'll come back to her when kelly
puts her back on
um there she is let me go back to erin
okay pause all right so uh let's go
ahead and talk to anthony anthony good
afternoon
i like your name brother you're in tampa
florida uh how can dr d and i help man
uh yes sir uh my question is is that
kind of a little bit of backstory
um thanks to kovit i nearly doubled my
income which is the good which is the
good part of bounds
went from went from selling insurance uh
on a pro sale basis to uh doing like
uber eats
and a couple other that
uh that ended up turning into a
full-time income for where'd it go
my problem is way to go man thank you
anthony's we know how to do it
we know how to get a job done went from
about 30
34 a year to probably going to be
pushing over 60 next year
wow um hold on hold on hold on don't
just blow by that
with uber eats and what else
and and like doordash and grubhub and
stuff like that doing that whole time
so you just straight you just straight
woke up and got
after it
pretty much and uh listen anthony before
i'm interrupting you and the question
you're gonna have for anthony o'neil
but listen quote-unquote you didn't
double your income because
covet you doubled your income because
you
ground it out and you worked your butt
off
okay right i want you to look in the
mirror at some
point and say all right that's pretty
good i did a good job
i'm proud of you for just seeing an
opportunity and for seeing a struggle
and then saying
not me not today i'm going after it i'm
going to make it happen make it happen
make it happen
good for you man all right get to your
question i'm sorry for interrupting you
but not really
i know big uh so the the question that i
have is uh
in 2019 i ended up getting a new vehicle
got this uh
got the loan stupid me um now that i
have this job that i
am driving a ton of miles every day on
um i am going to be upside down in my
vehicle
um pretty soon uh the question is
is that with with um
tax season coming up and everything i
think that i probably saved a little bit
more than what i'm actually going to be
um owing the ir uh irs for taxes
yeah and trying to hold on hold on
uh we're coming up to the clock here so
i want you to hold on okay we're gonna
put you back on the hood
and uh we'll come back to you after the
break all right
okay all right man hey this is the dave
ramsey we'll be right back
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the dave ramsey show dr
john dironi and myself anthony o'neil
ramsey personalities
uh sitting in and having a conversation
with you america about your life your
money
your relationships your mental health
and before going to break we had um
one of the best brothers i've ever met
on the radio show because his name is
anthony as well
uh was giving us a comment was talking
to us about his current situation as far
as and should he sell his car what's
going on
uh so update us again man as far as and
where you currently are and how we can
help
yeah uh so in in 2019
uh before covid everything before
switching jobs i
got a car got a loan stupid me um so
now that i am putting a ton of miles
on my vehicle pretty much every day i am
now
slightly upside down in my car
right now i owe about 16
on the vehicle and i have about another
nine
and credit card debt um two options that
i
that i'm kind of contemplating between
um and if there's a third please let me
have it but the the two options that i
that i'm looking at right now with the
money that i've
saved that i'm saved over and above what
i'm probably going to be oweing the irs
the tax season this year is to
sell my vehicle which right now
looking on my facebook marketplace and
what have you i can probably get about
13
14 for it and then pay the additional
uh two to three thousand out of pocket
on it and then get like a five thousand
dollar
cheap car for cash and get out from
underneath
the car payment or should i go ahead
and just throw the extra money that i
get
towards the credit card and get that
paid i
paid off as quickly as possible and then
work on the car
knowing that i'm going to be upside down
okay so you're banking 60k a year right
now
all right the only the only kind of debt
you have is 9k on the credit card 16k on
this vehicle and the vehicle is worth 14
000 um how much cash do you
have you said you had some cash right
now
um it it depends because i mean this is
my first year being a sole prop
so i i think that i i think that
throughout the year i've been saving a
little bit more than what i'm actually
going to be on the irs
so i'm not entirely certain how much i'm
going to have saved
once everything is said and done with
that okay okay
all right so here's what i'll do um
let me two questions for you answer this
one if you
did the debt snowball method paid off
the 9k on the credit card then jumped
over to the car
how long do you think it would take you
to pay off all of your debt both both
items
if you just stuck to that method how
long would it take you
um
theoretically thinking i'm thinking
maybe three four years three four years
all right
and if you sold the car today and you
went out there and bought a cash car and
then you just had a nine thousand
dollars how long would it take to pay
off to nine thousand dollars
uh i could probably get that paid off
pretty quickly probably a year and a
half two years
so which one do you what a year and a
half
two years or four years
uh the the two years sounds like the way
i would like to go because
it gives us a much shorter time frame my
only problem is that i know that what i
have is reliable and i
and whatever i get whatever i get a cash
car
would basically be a crap shoot since
i'm using it every day and putting a lot
of miles
that's that's kind of my one my dilemma
in getting a cash car
great so let's let's talk about that i
agree
you're driving this car every single day
i like the two-year method
how in the world can you take all right
how do we get your income up maybe five
thousand dollars more get on a very
straight budget
and then how do we turn your four years
into maybe two and a half years
to pay this car off quicker and then pay
your 9 000
off quicker i think that's the question
that you
you should ask yourself all right if i
do this i can be debt-free within two
years
so how can i keep the car and maybe be
debt-free within two years two and a
half years so you can so you can't have
a reliable car
my method is to help you get help you
become debt free
quickly that's that's why i'm here
and so i think if you're worried about
that cool how do we get this thing paid
off within two and a half years
can you do it yeah that uh uh i think i
could if i
if i can if i can knock the credit card
out i
think paying down the car should be a
piece of cake absolutely because
you're you're okay you know you have a
16 000
uh car right now that's worth 16 000
you're making 60k
i'm not upset with the math there and
you're not drowning in debt with a whole
bunch of other stuff
i think you can get that nine thousand
dollars really knocked out within the
next four months
and then just aggressively go after that
car i am
so fine with that uh so i would i would
say
if you're concerned about a reliable car
do that but you got to get aggressive
and you should be able to be debt-free
within two years
honestly okay very cool all right no
problem
sounds like a plan yeah keep up the hard
work man
so aaron is back with us she was uh
going early but she's back with us today
erin in
california fresno california good
afternoon how can dr d and i help
thanks for taking my call guys um so i
have a life insurance question
as to whether or not my husband and i
actually need to get it
so we became totally debt free in
october
um so we paid off about 170 grand in
student loans
and now we're done way to go yeah yeah
let me tell you the dance was real
afterwards
um so now we're in baby step three we
should have our six month emergency fund
by may
okay uh together we make 170 k before
benefits
and we have about 100k in our retirement
okay we don't have any kids
and we make within two thousand dollars
of each other
do we actually need life insurance yes
okay yeah um and and and here's why um
i mean i i didn't really hear you only
have a hundred thousand dollars in
retirement right now right
and let's just say so who's the bread
winner as far as
it are y'all pretty much but two
thousand dollars apart two thousand
dollars apart right
yeah yeah i'm i'm 86 he's 84. so it's
really
yeah you're crushing him baby i love it
it's not a
narration but it comes i'm from texas so
you know
i had a girl aaron you went to
california got a california guy and you
show him i appreciate that
yeah yeah yeah yeah so so your lifestyle
is your lifestyle based off of 170 000
income or is your lifestyle based off of
80 some thousand dollars a year
it's based off we live on 55. at a girl
live on 55. okay cool so here's the
truth
now we recommend in between 10 to 12
years on the term life insurance policy
uh with you all being 100 debt free
you're already living off of 55 000
a year um i would still say yes get some
insurance now will you need 10 to 12
you know will you need a about you know
well you need
two three million dollars probably not
no um
i say sit down have a conversation and
just honestly see okay
what do i need if you were to pass
husband if you were to pass
wife um what is a comfortable situation
and then go from there i would say
i would guess maybe right around like
maybe six years you know six
seven years maybe not a full 10 12. but
i would definitely say you need
some but just not all of it and aaron
the temptation here how old are you
i'm 32 he's 34. okay so the temptation
for someone in their young two young
folks like you guys
is you're doing a math problem here and
i sat in a room looking a wife in the
eye when her husband has passed away in
the next room i've done this multiple
times
and they're trying to do the math on i
gotta go to work on monday
right or i'm gonna have to go to work in
the next week
and what i want you guys to not focus so
there is a math component to this no
question but there is a psychological
component to this too and so in my house
my wife's got a phd she's brilliant she
can go make money tomorrow right
i want her and she wants me to be able
to grieve
properly to not have to think oh gosh
how am i going to eat next month
right we're able to pause for a second
and so that's the situation
you can't really wrap your head around
until you've sat in it right
and so i i'm a big fan of life insurance
it's worth that money to me it may not
make sense mathematically it's worth it
psychologically it's worth it
emotionally and spiritually it's worth
it for those moments of grief when they
show up
and they do just show up okay and so
that's why i'm i'm a big fan of it
oh man a great call yeah thank you so
much aaron for giving us a call
and uh man you're doing amazing love
exactly where you are and love what
you're doing
uh man dr d one hour down
it's been fun it's really been fun reset
three three seven eight nine get the
event
tonight tonight tonight tonight this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the number one show in america
the dave ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about
your life your money your relationships
your mental health my name is anthony
o'neil host of the popular
youtube show the table with anthony
o'neil and co-hosting today with me
is my one of my favorites dr john
deloney
host of the youtube and podcast show
the dr john deloney show the number here
is triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five
five two two five and america listen
some of you all i know right now are
frustrated i know some of you right now
are saying
what am i going to do different this
year to change what happened last year i
do not want to experience
the financial letdowns i had in 2020 i
want a new life i
want to reset my goals my vision
my life listen hold on we did that
we did it how do we do it we did it
january 1. we had this kumbaya moment
with ourselves and our little journals
and our day planners with all those
freaking ribbons in them
we did it yep and then 2020 one
yep shot out of the cannon backwards and
hit us in the mouth
yes and here we are again here we are
again and we gotta reset again
okay guys and so tonight uh our good
friends uh dave ramsey chris hogan
rachel cruz and craig rochelle are
hosting
a free can i say this one more time free
f-r-e-e free reset live stream event to
kick
start your money goals for 2021
they're going to give you the motivation
and guidance you need to hit the reset
button and say goodbye to money stress
for good so i want you to text the word
reset
our e-s-e-t to three three seven eight
nine so some of y'all not
you're not texting the word and let me
tell you right now your wife is gonna
thank you for texting the word reset
your husband is going to thank you for
texting the word reset your children
your great-grandchildren
your family are going to thank you down
the road
at the end of this year for texting the
word reset to 33789
you know why because your life is going
to change tonight
and what else are you going to be doing
nothing yeah we are dude we're going to
be you're not
you're not you know you're really not
and here's the thing for me you know
um everyone needs a reset in life
you can't reach your money goals if your
mind is not in a healthy play
place one of the key things john i'm
teaching specifically millennials
because that's that's my target audience
is that your mind is a business and when
i say your mind is a business i tell
young people mind your business because
your mind is a business
what you put into your mind will come
out of you
and what i love about this event tonight
we're going to put some
solid information into your mind to help
you
reset and recalibrate your mind so you
can go into 2021
with clear vision with with the process
with the plan
to not just reach your money goals but
just to reach your
life goals and that's key there because
it's not just going to be pom-poms and
and fireworks tonight and cotton candy
yeah it's going to be a plan
they're going to challenge you to not
live into the
nonsense and the hate and the
frustration and
everybody yelling at each other that's
going on in this country
they're gonna tell you to look in the
mirror they're gonna give you a plan so
you and your family you and your friends
you and your church group you
and you yeah can start walking the plan
to never have this nonsense happen
again and when you take care of you you
take care of your family you take care
of your street you take care of your
neighborhood and you take care of your
city
and then you take care of all of us
because we're all in this together yeah
we're all in it together and we want to
see you in and there's 200 000 plus
people we've already signed up i've
already signed up but you know what
there's there are millions of us in
america and so i want to encourage you
uh to join us tonight my friends my
mentor
um really helping all of us just reset
uh
we're gonna jump over to cleveland ohio
and talk to jordan jordan good afternoon
how can dr d and i help
hey mr o'neill hey dr d thanks for
taking my call hey man thank you so much
for calling in call me ao you ain't call
me mr o'neill man
i'm the young one call dr g the mr doc
all right all right sounds good
so um basically i am going to be
receiving
um a pretty significant amount of money
about two thousand dollars a month
for a va claim okay and
that is for the rest of my life okay um
we've been my wife and i are young we're
26. okay
um we've been good stewards of our money
uh up to this point we've got about 75
000
in the bank and no debt yes
both of us have our undergrads paid for
and completed
and she's currently in a master's
program on a scholarship wow
we are extremely blessed in every way
and now we just found out about this
payment that we're going to be getting
every month
yeah and feel a little guilty uh feel a
little
overwhelmed um what's that what's the
claim
uh for for disability from the military
okay so i want you to take all that
guilt you have
and i want you to to look at it like
it's a brick that you're holding your
hands i want you to put that down
okay okay the va does not write checks
for fun
they don't write checks for people to
feel good you gave your time your
service
you put it in your wife put hers in
and whatever settlement y'all came up to
with the va i want you to look in the
mirror as though it's
it's earned it's yours it is what it is
and um feeling guilty about it is not
going to help you be a steward of that
money it's not going to help you be a
steward of your mind every month when
that check comes in it's not going to
help you be a steward of your grandkids
okay so put that that guilt
down and then take that money and
follow the baby steps plan be a good
steward of it give it as you're able to
in the right places and um
have a joyful rock and roll life man
yeah jordan um
uh you're already being a good steward
of not just your financial resources but
not to get too spiritual in the show but
you're just being a good steward all the
way around
okay so i want you to celebrate that you
know god is trusting you
uh and i believe because he can trust
you with a few he's just elevating you
with more
and so continue that heart uh continue
having that heart continue doing what
you're doing but let's talk practical
man
what are some of you and your wife's
goals like are you as currently
homeowners right now
we are not home owners right now um we
have a five-year plan we want to own
three rental homes
okay um within the next five years and
paid for in cash
and this right here kind of puts the
mail in the coffin tour that's
gonna happen um our income's about a
hundred okay combined
so uh we're on track to knock that out
now
there we go pretty easily i think um but
yeah i just i just wanted to talk so i
appreciate you guys
saying that i just wanted to talk to
somebody about it i make sure
me and my wife weren't just in a
feedback loop um but we kind of ran
through the same motions already
with each other but it's good to hear
somebody else say that
it's did you were you a combat veteran
did you go overseas
no okay um so
man it's common just and you may know
this but we'll just put out there for
everybody listen
it is common to be a veteran who's not a
combat veteran
to be in a better financial situation
than your community some of your other
fellow vets
and think that you're scamming the
system you got something they don't
and i can't think he said you're being a
good steward you worked your butt off
you worked hard
you left something on the table for the
rest of us and i'm grateful for you
follow your plan and man walk with your
head held high brother yeah y'all are
doing it right all right this is amazing
i'm so i'm so happy for you too man
congrats
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and
interior shutters with easy online
ordering free shipping and a guaranteed
perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the dave ramsey show and my
name is anthony o'neil host of the
popular
youtube show uh the table with anthony
o'neil coming soon to podcast we'll be
announcing that here actually within the
next couple of weeks i'm really excited
about that
and my good friend dear friend uh the dr
john deloney who is the host of the
podcast and youtube
uh show the doctor john deloney stuff
you know one of the greatest things i
love about your show is man you talk
about some of the realest and
hardest thing on your show
you want to turn on your yeah here's the
thing here's the thing i got to cut off
people are struggling we're looking at
the data man marriages are in trouble um
people have been come they've become
great partners yeah they've become great
business operators as we've had to work
from home run families from home shuttle
kids back and forth figure out meals and
deliveries and
scrap and claw and man intimacy's gone
out the window marriages are struggling
relationships and dating relationships
are struggling people are putting off
this
and putting on that it's a tough tough
season
not to mention just the acute psychology
of being in debt the acute psychology of
getting laid
off or maybe gonna get laid off or all
this political trash that's going on
yeah people are man they're just spun
out and so on
yeah we are getting into this part you
you went safe but i i wouldn't say that
you guys there are some people stuff
that we all
battle um and i think dr john will
uh be safe in the political way of
saying things but he talks about some
things that are embarrassing with
you know that i think a lot of us in
this in america have
see i don't think they're embarrassing i
think we don't talk about it to our
detriment right yeah but i mean one of
your shows is be honest here on the dave
ramsey show we talked about it yesterday
you talk about the battle of pornography
and how that's
messing up some marriages you're helping
marriages get
through that individuals trying to
figure out what's cool what's not cool
what's happening to my brain what's not
all that stuff
right so we don't get those kind of
questions on the day randy
sell the truck sell the truck right but
what i want to tell america is
listen if you're struggling if there are
some things that you're going
through and you really just want to get
some sound
counsel some sound advice about anything
when it comes to your mental health when
it comes to your marriage when it comes
to
your relationship this man has an
amazing team
kelly who's this phone screener for
today ram just shows his phone screener
um and i'm telling you right now that
they're setting him up to to win and to
help you
and i really i mean i watch his show
every day and i'm like man this dude is
talking about some real
heavy stuff but you're saving so many
lives
and marriages well i appreciate that you
know and so america i want y'all to go
over and check my man out on
youtube um it is the dr john deloney
show download the podcast when did your
podcast come out
um we're at show 67 i think 65 so what
days
monday wednesday friday cool yeah yes
when it comes out yeah thank you james
uh his producer uh james he didn't know
his own schedule y'all so yeah
monday wednesday and friday is when his
show comes out so
listen uh check him out america i'm
telling you right now it will bless you
and uh if you really want some help give
kelly his phone scream or call and
she'll get you on there hopefully you
know how she rolls
uh but uh she'll let you know we're
going out to austin texas
and we're going to have a conversation
with sam sam good afternoon how can dr d
and i help
hey guys um so my husband and i
are between baby steps three and four
and we've kind of been paused here for
about a year
okay and we have um 15 000
in savings above our emergency fund and
we're wondering
um for trying to buy a house
or safe from retirement we don't really
feel like we have the funds to do
both so what should we focus on
and um how should we
how long is it okay for us to pause the
baby steps i guess
okay talk to me sam um
fifteen thousand dollars above your
three to six months
um already okay how old are you and your
husband
we are 28 and we actually
paused our babies up to make the stork
fund
um because we have an eight month old
all right
congratulations i just literally learned
about the word stork
yesterday with dave for the first time
and i was like stop
quit in the world he was like yeah
they're storing money sending money
inside you know to pause babysitter i
said okay cool great that's a new word
so
yeah second time hearing it today and i
wasn't confused so cool
well i actually heard it earlier on the
show and i thought it was cool
love it i love it i love it so here's
the thing um sam
how much house are you trying to
purchase
um for us we feel like somewhere between
260 and 300 000 okay
so we know the 20 down payment
and the 15-year fixed mortgage so
to get there you know we really need
like 60 000 and maybe even a little bit
more
just to have for furniture and
appliances and stuff that we don't want
wrapped into our
mortgage good for you good for you great
yeah
and that's lovely and so here's the
thing i don't have a problem with you
pausing at your age right now pausing
uh baby step number four which is
investing 15
of your income into a 401k or roth ira
or any type of retirement account and
here's why because
you are making an investment by
purchasing a home now
here's what we also teach you want to do
the minimum of ten percent
uh to put down on your home so if you
did the minimum of ten percent on a
two hundred thousand dollar home you're
looking at twenty thousand um if you're
doing a minimum of 10 percent on a 250
000 homes you're looking at about you
know 25 to 30 000.
so you all are close to that 10 number
so we always say to minimum
now yes we want you to put down 20 to
help you avoid
the pmi absolutely if you can
but if you and your husband are in a
great place of life to where you guys
are okay with
you know putting down 10 10
to get into the home that's okay that's
that we just said a minimum of 10
percent
to get into a home as long as you
finance it for 15
years with the fixed rate
but you guys are not in a rush though
correct
um no we're not yeah so we actually
need to wait a little bit longer um
my husband just changed jobs and he
works for a home builder and one of
their benefits
is you can get a great deal on a brand
new home
it's a discounted because it's an
employee benefit so
to take advantage of that he has to work
there for a year
so my other question i guess my
follow-up
is should we at least be
heading towards his 401k what the
employer matches
so here's the thing baby steps three b
is before baby steps four
five six and seven so you do all of four
through seven all at the same time
now because you do have a fully funded
emergency
fund um i don't mind you investing
and saving at the same time so if you're
in a comfortable position
and you feel as if you can go ahead and
invest at 15
because i what don't want you i want you
to invest a little bit i either want you
to invest
all the 15 percent invest and save a
little for your house
or put all into your house and then
start investing into it you see what i'm
saying
so it's like if you're going to start
investing yeah either or so
aggressively safe so you can get into
the house quicker
and you can start investing a lot more
which is the 15
or invest the 15 and start saving and
setting aside money
and also anticipating the huge discount
you all get
from building a house with your husband
being a part of uh
the company that builds homes that's
what i recommend okay
all right all right well
um thank you guys so much oh man thank
you thank you congratulations on that
little
that little eight month old yeah man
it's it's amazing how i'm
man i just love the fact of hearing
young people
in their 20s starting to call into the
show
and ask questions like hey how do i do
this we want to do it right we want to
avoid debt we want to build wealth we
want to be home owners
we want to travel um
this is this is starting to become new
man and we want to do it the right way
that's the thing we watched our parents
grind we got these student loan payments
and we went whoa
and we googled what do i do now and dave
ramsey we don't know this guy
yeah help yeah you said on the internet
you could help what do we do now
and it's not some get rich scheme and
not some fairy dust man you've got to
put in the hard grinding work right i
have to
you you really do have to and so young
people listening right now man i'm proud
of y'all i don't care what no one says
about our generation
we got this and we will be better than
our our parents
uh we will provide for our families we
will
build true wealth put the hard work in
right we're going to put the hard work
in right and we're going to be all right
and i'm so excited for the next
generation after my children
they're gonna be some wealthy generation
of group of people
i'm excited this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had
chm chm saved our life talking about
financial lives
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but it is a budget-friendly option and
the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
learn more today and check us out at
chministries.org
that's chministries.org
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the dave ramsey show
my name is anthony o'neill host of the
table with anthony o'neil
joining me is dr john demoni host of the
dr john deloney show and drd
we got a blinds.com question of the day
talk to us brother that's right find out
for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window covering
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsey to get the best deal
rules and restrictions apply today's
question comes from michelle
in texas michelle writes my father
recently passed
and left 50 percent of his house to his
four kids oh jeez i can't tell you
and 50 to our mom in his living trust
my mom married two years after his death
her and her new husband lived in the
house for five years
and then those folks sold the house and
moved across the country
when she sold the house which netted
them over four hundred thousand dollars
i asked about the inheritance for us for
girls
she said she created a new living trust
with her new husband
and we would be getting the inheritance
from my dad upon her death
i was shocked and very sad as i feel
like my dad's gift is not getting the
honor that it should
thanks for the help
that's messy anthony very very
messy my mom married two years after
his death my father recently passed on
that 50 of the house
to his four kids and 50 to our mom and
his living trust
yeah you need to get an attorney yeah
well you got to make a decision here
number one do you want to get an
attorney go after mom
yeah um essentially 200 000 dollars
that should have been hers yes and then
there was four kids that were going to
divide up the other
200 000 bucks which would have been 50
grand a piece
and um because her living trust should
only cover her 200
000 not what was automatically given to
you from your father and so
um i would definitely just call your mom
say hey mom listen legally
you really don't have the grounds to
stand on i'm here
and we're asking if we can uh resolve
this respectfully
you know with love we're this is family
we shouldn't have to include an attorney
uh i'd actually go before that i'd get
all four kids and get them on the same
phone call or the same zoom call and say
here's the reality of our situation yeah
we want to have this conversation do we
want to do this with
mom do we want to are we all ready to go
to war with mom
or do one of us want to write a letter
to mom and just say hey
we don't feel this was the right way to
do this right um and it may be that
mom got some bad advice maybe that mom
i'm gonna think the best of mom right
now but
yeah it looks pretty shifty all right
but once you sell that house once that
house is sold
um then that money needs to be divvied
up in the right way
absolutely absolutely praying for you
ken is with us
in uh los angeles california ken good
afternoon how can dr d and i help
hey how you guys doing today doing great
man how about yourself
i'm all right my head's above water so i
can't really complain but i'm still
swimming
excellent brother that's good attitude i
love it how can we help man
um so i got a little bit of an issue
here that i've been thinking about for a
while
um i'm losing my job here by the end of
the month
um a couple of guys me and a couple of
guys are
i've been given another job offer but
without a pay increase
at a different location um it's a lot
further away
my only issue is i no longer want to
live in california anymore
i've been thinking about moving out
since last year um
haven't really took that dive so
just wondering if i should do that or
not i got a little bit of money in
savings
and i got some more money and a checking
account
so yeah i'm just running into a little
bit of issue here
our friend ken coleman says don't jump
off the dock until you got a boat there
to jump into and this one is very
tempting
[Music]
you you don't know this ken but you're
the only one that we've talked to in the
last six months who wants to leave
california by the way
and i'm no i'm being sarcastic brother
every person we talk to
like i'm getting out here i'm getting
out of here um man
i get the sentiment i would take if i'm
you i would take that second job and
begin really putting in the work to see
what it's gonna look like to get another
job
right like where would you actually live
where would you go just
i mean you can man you can hop on a
train and pack it up old school how old
are you
um i'm not really 30s okay um kids
married anything like that no kings i'm
single
okay um no marriage no debt no no
ken where were they uh where's the other
job offer where is that
um
area okay so it's still in california
yeah it's still in california okay so
right now the
your priority is finding you another job
another source of income
all right and so if you know you're
going to lose this job within the next
month or so what i'm doing is if your
goal is to leave california start
applying
for other jobs outside of california if
you do not land something by the time
you lose your job
and by the time you you get rid of your
emergency fund then yes you need to take
that job
uh that is still there in california now
if you can
land something inside of um
outside of california then absolutely i
would definitely
uh i would leave california i love
california i'm from california my family
still lives in california
but right now it's not beneficial as far
as an income money
and just the way the state is being run
right now that's just my personal
opinion that's not dave's that's not
john's that's
that's my personal opinion i will leave
but if i can't find another job i'm not
leaving california
without some source of income and
without a job and without stability
i'm going to stay there and while you
work in this other job if you have to go
this route
continue looking i would encourage you
to jump on the kingcommons.com website
and use his website nice website but use
his
a resume builder from his website he'll
teach you how to build a strong resume
and start shipping that stuff around man
outside of california
but i would start the process make sure
you take care of the priority
get a job get some source of income in
right now so you can be a stable young
man
make sense yeah that's funny all right
man
appreciate you for calling in
um elena is in washington seattle
good afternoon elena how can dr d and i
help
oh good afternoon thank you for uh
talking with me
yeah so my husband and i just paid off
our home mortgage in december
that's awesome yeah so we're excited
about that so
at this point you know our home is it's
fairly old
we we live on 15 acres and
desperately need a renovation remodel
electrical
all kinds of stuff plus we have an old
barn that we'd like to
fix up as well and so the cost of that
probably is going to be approximately
300
000 so i guess the question is you know
we are both 46 years old
we plan to retire when we're 60. we have
about 400
000 in retirement as of right now
so do we save and pay for our remodel
cash or do we refinance and get a loan
for that i mean what
i guess you just worked so
hard to unshackle yourself from the
from from the machine you all put in so
much time you ground you clawed you
scratched
don't hook yourself back don't chain
yourself up voluntarily back to another
300 000
loan against the place you finally paid
off
please please don't do that i know you
want that kitchen in that barn and that
pinterest is killing you right now it's
killing you
don't yeah okay don't don't
don't don't don't you're you're free you
are free you are free
don't voluntarily get your husband in a
ipad with pinterest on it and go back
into another cage
and smiling and hug each other and slam
that door shut behind you don't do that
yeah and here's why elena you're you're
getting close to the end
of the time you want to work so so these
next few years
you need to be very intentional with
every decision that you make that gets
you
close to your goal and your end goal
right now is to retire inspired in the
words of chris hogan
your end goal is to retire a millionaire
your end goal
is to retire in a healthy financial
place you do not want to be 60 years old
getting ready to retire and you're still
paying for renovations you did
15 years ago because they're not going
to be cool in 15 years yeah yeah
so focus on the end goal if you're close
to it
calm down pay cash and i promise you
you'll think yourself that you called
into the show
talked to this crazy guy named dr john
dalone and this cool guy named anthony
o'neil
and we talked you out of don't do it
financing don't do it
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
tonight is the night you guys january
12th and 12th at 7
pm uh that you can reset your future you
can reset the direction
you are going with our free reset
live stream event uh to kickstart your
money goals for the year 2021.
uh dave ramsey chris hogan rachel cruz
and one of my favorite
uh preachers of the gospel craig
rochelle will give you the motivation
and guidance
you need to reset your life
for this year now a lot of this will be
around money because you have three
money
experts on the stage um and craig
rochelle is
uh i call him like the life expert you
know he's just
he just has a lot of wisdom when it
comes to really having a
a good life and i want to encourage you
to stop what you're doing right now i
want you to pause what you're doing
right now
i want you to to get off social media
right now i want you to go to your text
uh messaging app on your cell phone and
i want you to text the word reset
r-e-s-e-t to three three seven eight
nine
right now get them set up one more time
text reset r-e-s-e-t
two three three seven eight nine
and what you're gonna do is you're gonna
sign up and you're going to take the
first step towards
lasting lasting financial peace or you
can go to daveramsey.com forward slash
reset and here's what i love and we've
been talking about this
this entire hour and the reason why we
are just hammering this
in on you is because i remember uh
meeting a young lady john and she
was telling me about the year 2020 and
she said
i need this year to be different just i
i cannot
afford for this year year 2021
to be the same as 2020. and she says
it has to be different and i'll tell her
one thing it will be different
if you're different choose that's right
that's it it will be different
if you become different
and the first way and the first
ingredient to becoming different
is to reset your mind is to reset how
you think of things how you process
things
how you evaluate things and that's
what's going to happen tonight
with dave with chris with rachel and
with craig
and with the hundreds of thousands of
people who will be watching
we are all going to get a reset and when
we reset
man we start off fresh now here's what
we're saying here's what we're not
saying we're not saying this year is
going to be easier
but you can approach this year better
with the fresh
perspective on life in moms and dads
here's your big moment we say it all the
time
the kids don't listen to you they
watch you and they watch you and they
watch you
so tonight if you've been thinking man
i've got to start doing this a little
bit differently my kids are driving me
crazy but
now's the time that you can step up
you can set an example you can tell all
the kids hey everybody's cell phone's
going in a bin tonight
all of them mine included we're turning
them off or put them in a basket
we're going to turn on the tv we're
gonna get some nonsense food
we're all doing this as a family
everybody
from little josephine who's five to my
18 year old kids who are planning on
going to college we're all gonna have
notes
and we're gonna sit down and we're gonna
get some not only some some good pep
talk
some good wisdom and some good uh
excitement
we're gonna get a plan do this and do
this and do this
and as a family we're gonna reset as an
individual we're gonna reset as
communities we're going to reset
literally hundreds of thousands of
people
have rsvp'd for for this free event i
tell you what anthony when they told me
what the goal was
behind closed doors i smiled and i was
like there ain't no way
[Laughter]
there ain't no way and more and more and
more people are saying
we're coming we thought we thought the
calendar was just gonna roll over and
everyone's gonna exhale the universe is
gonna be like all right y'all had enough
20 20 was enough
yeah oh man 20 heading started anthony i
love it no i
the wildness hasn't started well it
started let's be honest the wildness has
started but
man why you're not going to do anything
else do this do this do this
yeah text the word reset resct two
three three seven eight nine and go to
dave ramsey dot com four slash reset and
i promise you
uh you will be happy john where are we
going next man we are gonna go
to blaine in greensboro north carolina
yes what's up blaine how are we doing
doing great how you doing guys
outstanding what can we do to help
brother uh hey
my wife and i own a rental house and
wanted to get some guidance on whether
it's best to
sell or go ahead and keep that so i
purchased it
out of college it's been a great house
for the last
12 or so years uh turns a profit every
month
we no longer live in that city i'm
acting as
a property manager we only owe about 17
000 left on that house um scheduled to
pay it off in the next three months
but if we if we do sell it we can
basically pay off our primary home
and um be you know debt-free sell it
okay anthony and i are gonna disagree
here i'm gonna tell you why
i'm not gonna i'm not saying i disagree
but i wanna hear a little bit more
information because 17
000 to pay off a house and then you have
another extra set of cash flow coming in
and you focus on just paying off your
mortgage that might be a
good decision down the road yeah i don't
know you want to be a landlord in
another town
oh this is in another town yes correct
i miss that so i am so sorry i am with
john delony here suddenly sell the house
america 2020 is turning around anthony
and deloney on the same page
it's going to happen now blaine talk to
me a little bit more
how much is the house worth because you
owe 17 on it i heard that but how much
is the house worth
it's worth about 275 so it's in a really
good location
um and would would go very fast
yeah okay and how much do you own your
current mortgage
we owe about 260. 260. okay
now any other debt no other debt
okay do you have a fully funded
emergency fund
we are working on that uh we've got
about hundred thousand retirement
um we just need to put some into the
emergency fund so you have six hundred
thousand dollars
in retirement right now and then
um you have 275 coming in from this sort
of equity so you have fifteen thousand
dollars left on
left over from once you pay off your
home
you can put that how much do you need
for three months man
for your emergency fund yeah i'd say
you know uh twenty thousand dollars
would be nice twenty thousand will put
you at a good comfortable three months
what's your income right now is it one
thirty
one thirty yeah pay off the house take
that fifteen thousand dollars put into
the bank
very next month you're putting five
thousand dollars into the bank so you
can have your immediate three months
um of uh three months of emergency
because it sounds like you gave yourself
some cushioning to 20
000 so i'm okay with that um and then
from there here's what i would suggest
now you're in a comfortable place i am a
huge fan of of real estate
dave is a huge fan of real estate so now
the next move is
how do you save back up to get back into
the real estate business
inside of north carolina you know that's
that's the next move because i want you
to start thinking about
what are some other streams of income
you can start generating in to start
building your net worth
um as long as you're fully funded uh
you're with the emergency fund as long
as you have
15 percent going into your roth ira and
your your 401k
retirement plans from there i would
definitely look into all right let's set
aside some money
so we can start buying some cash
property and we can start generating
some other streams of income for us so
hey blaine before we hang up i have a
quick question for you what do you make
every month what do you net
off of your rental property
we need about 500 and it's just been
going right back into paying down the
principal
so what is your mortgage every month
about a thousand dollars merry christmas
yeah merry christmas if you go pay your
house off you're gonna net
500 you're gonna double your money every
month does that make sense and then
think about it down the road
i'm not really worried about the monthly
payment down the road i look at the
equity of the home
and so um you're in a good place right
there blaine i'm really really really
excited for you man thank you so much
for calling in
congratulations hey thank you i love
that conversation
you know i love i love that man i'm
telling you right now
because that's what i'm doing my house
right now the town home that i'm in
that's going to be
a airbnb or a rental property so you're
racing to pay it off as fast as possible
it will be paid off soon it's a four
bedroom four bath a
nice tall overlooking the city with a
rooftop on it and i literally bought
that place
i don't want to live there forever i
don't like it like that yep uh but i
bought it so i can think about the
future
gotcha i want my kids to have that when
i get older
you know what i'm saying and so i love
talking about it but we gotta do it the
right way man can i do it the right way
gotta do it the right way you understand
what i'm saying
be smart be smart be smart this that's
right this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dalacar
rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out to have
a conversation about your life your
money your mental health
your relationships my name is anthony
o'neil host of the popular youtube show
the table with anthony o'neil
and co-hosting today is the
one and only dr john demonia host of the
popular
the dr john deloney youtube and podcast
show
we're here to take your calls and y'all
we love talking about
anything and so give us a call triple
eight eight two
five five two two five again that's
triple eight eight two
five five two two five and i wanna start
off this segment by just simply giving
you a simple reminder
okay that tonight is a night that could
help
change your life okay tuesday january
12th at 7 pm
uh dave ramsey chris hogan rachel cruz
and craig rochelle
will give you the motivation and
guidance you need to hit
reset to hit the reset button and say
goodbye to stress
money stress life stress maybe not
for good when a life stress but at least
for good for the money stress
tonight is a free event a free reset
live stream event to kick start your
money goals
and so what i want you to do is text the
word reset to three three
seven eight nine again that is reset
to three three seven eight nine or you
can go to dave ramsey dot com
forward slash reset so here's your
options for tonight
go home
be annoying listen to your kids be
annoying
or go i don't know sit around and sing
kumbaya together
you watch a get into bed as soon as
possible you watch some netflix show
they all go off into the rooms on their
own devices
you and your wife are watching your own
shows she's thumbing through something
on
whatever you're thumbing through
whatever device on your whatever
you're watching a screen and you're
watching your screens in front of
another screen
or you can put your money where your
mouth is
get everybody together say tonight is
the night we're all getting on the same
page as a family
as a as a dating couple i'm getting on
the same page by myself
i'm just sitting on my couch i've been
stuck in this place for nine months i
got a dog next to me now i got this dog
from the pound i don't even know where
this dog came from anthony i don't even
know this talk
we're gonna sit down i got my yellow pet
out
we're just gonna say no more we're gonna
say no more and get four of the best
voices in the united states of america
you can turn off the dumpster fire
that's the news right now you can turn
off the dumpster fire that is
the plans we thought we had for 2021 and
then it shot out of the canada dud
and we can just say all right man we got
four of the of the best and brightest in
the united states of america going to
walk us through
hope walk us through reset walk us
through a plan
reset to 33789 i don't know what else
you could possibly be doing with your
time tonight
do it do it do it do it i used to love
me some peer pressure in college
do it why would you not do it
i love it man i love your energy around
this holy batman
just do it what else you gonna be doing
you're amazing i know what else i could
be doing right now
and that is talking to lynn in tulsa
oklahoma uh good afternoon
uh good afternoon lynn how can delta d
and i help
hi guys um i'm engaged and i'm planning
for my
married financial life okay good for you
i have uh money saved
and my fiance has debt so when we get
married i'd like to pay off
his debt um but then my
idea was to live like we're on baby step
two
until we put that money back into my
savings
but i don't know if that's going
overboard and since i have money
i shouldn't live like i'm in debt but
i think it'd be good practice for him
because he's just getting into dave
ramsey we're taking fpu
this uh spring when are you getting
married
october 2021. okay
so you can continue to when you're
talking about
your financial situation right now until
october
it's going to be yours and his right
when you're talking about the
shared debt repayment program the plan
y'all are going to get on as a
couple it's y'alls so the moment you
walk down that aisle
that is not his debt that is y'all's
debt
the moment he walks down that aisle that
is not your savings
that is y'alls savings and then you
immediately kick right back into
whatever baby step
you all are on because y'all will have
debt
you all will have savings y'all will
aggressively have two incomes hopefully
going after this thing
and then y'all are gonna work on this
plan together does that make sense
it does it does and listen to you
you you all you almost didn't take a
breath while i was talking
when you get married
it's y'alls okay
there is no ifs ands or buts there's
nothing that's going to divide your
relationship up
or spin your brand new marriage off into
the ditch faster
than yours and mine his and his and hers
but i did so much work before we go hey
we're getting married now
okay same plan same team same same
united goals
same legacy that y'all are both building
lynn how much debt does he have
by when we get married it should
probably be 25 000
okay how much does he make a year
about 55 okay what does he do for a
living
he works in the factory okay cool bands
all right factory what kind of a 25k is
that is that student loans
it's a personal loan and a credit card
okay personal on the credit card well
how much does he have on the credit
cards
it's about half and half yeah how much
do you have in savings
you're precious at your precious
precious savings yes i can tell how
precious it is to you how much you got
in it
well um in non-retirement savings i have
about three hundred thousand
okay yeah so let me ask you this
question wait what
she has to range a thousand we could
tell that lynn has been
the the wise steward and saving how old
are you lynn
i'm 36 yeah how old is your husband your
future husband
40 45. okay all right so here's the
thing
i want to have a conversation with your
husband okay if your husband was there i
would have a conversation like this
hey we're going to do this and this is
what we are going to do like what dr
john said
we are going to pay off your debt um but
i would want to know
what is his mindset you know like where
how does he think about money or what
does he think about money
how is he perceiving things because what
i want to make sure is that when you two
get married
you do not end up back in baby step two
because of
decisions you both made i don't think
you will make them because of your
lifestyle today
but i'm not i'm not sure to what your
husband your future husband will say
okay so just make sure that before you
all get married that you two get on the
same page
when it comes to finances now to answer
your part two question
um we say we say
to have three to six months of
emergencies sitting aside
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
is more than
six months it's invested yeah okay okay
cool so what's in your actual checking
account
savings account i have
more cash than normal because i'm i'm
gonna be paying for a wedding
and then hopefully um we'll buy a house
um so i do have more cash than why is
about 45
yeah in actual cash yeah so here's the
thing
i would definitely just say make sure
you have a minimum of six months
if you have more than six months in
there no don't stay on baby step two and
don't stay on baby step three
enjoy your life move on to baby steps
four through seven and enjoy your first
year of marriage
the day after that wedding you write a
check and pay his debt off yeah well
pay y'all's debt off yo ah well played
this is a dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities whether
your goals are to get an education
serve your country or have a better life
the army national guard
can help get you there plus they offer
unbelievable financial benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five again the number here
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
we have about 45 minutes left in this
hour that we would love to talk
with you dr john deloney and myself
anthony o'neil ramsey personalities
and here we're talking about uh
relationships money you
name it everyone talk with alex alex out
in dallas texas good afternoon alex how
can dr d and i help
guys thank you so much for taking my
call i know thank you so much for giving
us a call how can we serve man
so i uh i'm on baby step two i've got
about
five thousand dollars left before i
finish up and can move on to uh
doing my six month emergency fund i i
just finished off paying one
loan and this is my last one it's a
student loan
um i'm fortunate enough to work for a
company that
helps me with my debt repayment and at
present they are
paying more than the minimum i have on
my student loan
and so my question was would it be okay
to move on to baby step
three while i have uh my company working
on baby step two
um so i i can work on that emergency
fund
okay that's a great question man um uh
so it's gonna be a tricky question so my
answer's gonna be like a yes and a no
and you'll see why uh how much longer do
you have
to pay this off
so if i were to attack it without
assistance it would take about three and
a
half
years say it again three and a half
years
three and a half months if i were to do
it without um
without any assistance perfect all right
so here's what i'm gonna do
so let's just say yes to make it simple
for you yes start move
start parking money into baby set number
three as far as an emergency fund
then what you do is say for an example
something happens in the next two months
and let's say you have to leave the
company
and you lose out on that then
immediately you will go into that
savings account
and pay off for the rest of your debt
and then pick back up on baby set three
does that make sense definitely
yeah it's very helpful yeah so i would
definitely do that just go ahead and
just start parking money to your
uh babysit three aggressively you know
so that way you can get to three months
maybe
within the next um uh three to five
months and then from there boom
you know if something does happen great
you got the money to take care of it if
something doesn't happen
great you're already ahead of the game
such a great question man thanks thanks
so much for calling in
for sure thank you so much guys thank
you josh is with us in ontario good
afternoon josh how can uh dr d and i
help
hi anthony hi john how are you guys
today yeah man we were doing great man
thanks so much
much better since you've called in how
can we start um i have a
question i'm self-employed i started my
own business
two and a half years ago okay i had one
part-time employee
and it's going well where we're making
good money and it's a good job
but to develop the business
i need to start putting systems in place
and
business process in place and i've
spoken to
a business coach now it costs
a considerable amount of money to get a
business coach
what's the consideration to grow
the business how much is how much it's
going to cost
uh 1500 u.s i guess it's about 2 000
canadian
okay all right that's a month yes
okay all right go ahead
i was wondering what if you guys think
that would be worth it
to uh to get a coach to help develop
these
business processes i'm always a fan of
getting an expert who can walk alongside
me to
help me do things that i don't know how
to do
and there's a cool new trend now to just
be like ah dude bro just get on youtube
you don't need none of that you can just
and some of that stuff
is true i learned how to fix the you
know the
side mirror that i knocked off when i
backed my wife's car into the
the post outside our house i was able to
get on youtube and to figure that out
sometimes the there's a way to take some
of this expertise and coaching and they
make it sound like it's a bunch of forms
and having somebody who will walk
alongside you during the ups and downs
of figuring this out when you get
nervous who's going to answer
a text or a phone call late at night or
early in the morning or turn your stuff
around in 24 hours
to not only give you the information but
to help with the implementation
and the process i think that is often
can be well well well worth its money
what i want to know from a coach is do
you know what you're talking about
if somebody is just a consultant to be a
consultant they're
not very useful for me i want someone
who's been there who knows what they're
talking about who
meets with people regularly understands
both personally
and experientially what people are going
through and can actually provide me true
expertise what makes dave dave is that
he went through it and then he sat at a
card table in his living room for years
and continues to be the ceo of a multi
multi-million dollar corporation
that still talks to the front line
customer every single day for
three hours a day that makes him an
experiential
expert a knowledge expert you know and
we're sitting here reading
content during the breaks to make sure
we know what we're talking about um
and continue to meet with people
regularly so man you get the right coach
behind you
they're well worth their money um it'd
be a great investment
i've made those investments myself i'm
looking at a particular kind of coach
right now for myself
about something totally unrelated to my
content just from my life and so
i do it anthony what do you think i mean
i think any time you can get a mentor or
a coach
um is a great opportunity if it's a
great opportunity
do it um i think i will also assess my
financial situation
i want to make sure that i'm not
spending this money 1500 you know
us dollars um and it's putting me in a
bind and it's making me i'm having to
borrow the money or i'm having to
do things that i shouldn't be doing to
get this money and the key thing for me
when i look for mentors or
business coaches or programs you know we
offer here
a program called entre leadership that
helps a lot of our
small businesses elevate to the next
level i look for results
you know you have a lot of people who
can say a lot of good things but
what are the results have they produced
other people to be successful
have they helped other businesses get to
the next level so josh i think you have
to sit down
one ask yourself okay is this a wise
move for me financially
will it will hundred dollars or a
thousand or whatever the price is
wherever you may land
will it hurt me if it will not hurt you
okay cool great i have the money it's in
my budget cool
two okay ask that person to send you
proof of results to send you proof of
other companies they've helped
get to the next level once you have
those two questions
answered yes then i will move forward
and then once you get i think i can't
remember what our
program requires i think it requires
something in between five or seven
employees i
i can't remember the exact stuff i would
definitely look onto entre leadership's
website
see if you can get down with us they're
the best in the business but i do
believe
there are certain kind of uh parameters
that we require so we can work with you
um but look us up but then at the same
time just make sure you ask the right
questions to whoever you look for
all right josh perfect thank you guys
hey thank you man hey josh one more
thing
one more thing don't spend the money on
a coach if you're not going to do what
they recommend
yeah we'll buckle down and do and work
with them and
drive as hard as we can a good coach is
going to make you really uncomfortable a
good coach is going to push you
harder than you can push yourself a good
coach is going to give you information
about you
and your company and your business that
you don't necessarily want to see that's
going to make you have to
pivot do things differently hire
somebody else etc
don't go to a personal trainer if you
don't want to lift the weights right
don't go to nutritionist if you want to
keep eating pizza for breakfast
don't get a business coach if you're not
going to change your life don't get a
mentor if you're going to talk more than
a mentor oh my gosh
you know that's one of the things i'm
always telling people listening right
now
so we talked about business coaches but
i want to i want to talk about this
going into the break
um the reason why some of you are not as
successful is because when you do get a
mentor
you talk more than a mentor actually
talk you have two eyes and two ears for
a reason and one mouth
listen and watch more than you talk i
watch
dave's every move do i do every single
thing dave does
no i listen to every single word that
dave says
um do i do 100 of what he says to do
when it comes to money yes
you know um but i i listen
more than i talk because he's the expert
he
is where i want to be in life and so if
you get a business coach if you get a
mentor if you get a marriage counselor
if you get a
listen listen shut up okay
listen that's it listen and try it
and if it doesn't work cool but at least
you try
something new
i'm a little frustrated but i'm being
why because this is
the day for him to show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
america tonight don't forget to text the
word reset
r-e-s-e-t to 3-3-7-8-9 to sign up and
take the first step
toward lasting financial peace dave
ramsey chris hogan rachel cruz and craig
rochelle
will be giving america the motivation
and guidance we
all need to hit the reset button and say
goodbye
to money stress life stress you
name it it's tonight at 7 pm it is 100
free free free all you have to do is
text the word reset
r-e-s-e-t to three three seven eight
nine or
go to dave ramsey dot com forward slash
re-set
uh jenny is with us in uh new york good
afternoon uh
jenny good how can drd and i help
hi guys i'm huge fans of yours it's an
honor to be talking to you
oh man we are a huge fan of you
how can we help so
i have an 18 month old baby boy
and i have decided that i would like to
make my shovel a little bit bigger
so i have a job offer from a daycare but
it's just not something that i
really want to be doing long term and
i'm wondering if i should
like with the daycare i'd be able to
take my son with me and i'm wondering if
i should seek out
some sort of employment that i'd be more
comfortable with long term
but i would also have to put my son in
daycare does that make sense
yeah yeah yeah so i get it it's like hey
if i go to this job
i actually get the discount because my
son can go with me
and i have to pay as much whenever i go
to another job i'm have to pay 100
of the daycare so you're you're in a
very interesting situation let me ask
you this question
what what do you really want to do you
know like what's
what's your what are you passionate
about because there's this is a bigger
than just money question isn't it yeah
yeah um well right now i'm i just
finished my associate's degree in
december
um i'm transferring but ideally i would
be transferring into
a psychology program okay um
and i'm eventually i would like to have
my
masters in that so i can teach either
in high school or post-secondary
education okay
don't laugh at that that's a good dream
and don't
doubt yourself you're raising a mom
you're raising a son you're going to
school you're kicking butt
don't doubt yourself you're going to get
all that knocked out yeah so you got
that
you want to be a school teacher that's
great okay right now the process is you
got to go through school get the
education
so you can become a schoolteacher
correct
right all right cool can you do that
while working at daycare
um i probably could it would just make
um right now i'm in baby step two so it
would make
my baby step two take a little bit
longer okay
okay all right i'm fine with that as
long as you're cash flowing
the rest of your school process yes
absolutely yeah yeah
how much left on your debt how much do
you owe
um 17 000 all together
and how long would it take you to get
that just knocked out completely
it'll take her a while if she's working
at a daycare
yeah this well right now i only make
about
fifteen hundred dollars a month yeah and
with the daycare i would probably
that one i did the math and i think the
most that i can make is probably
300 a week yeah good because it's a
floater position so it's only like five
hours
right okay so so we got to get your
shovel bigger like you said in the very
beginning
beginning um i want to connect you and
honestly
um introduce you to ken coleman ken
coleman i call him
our uh make your shovel guy bigger i
mean makes
that didn't make any sense ken coleman
is a guy who
can help you make your shovel bigger he
is the shovel
yeah guy i want you to listen to his
show
i want you to read his book i'm going to
send you a free copy of his book
the proximity principle okay um and
i want you to read it all right and then
also what i want you to do
is just go on his website he has a lot
of resources when it comes to
how to find a job how to land your dream
job and your dream job is to be a
teacher
and so um i want you to do that so here
here's
answer your questions we may should be
very practical for you yes
take the job okay take the job you're
gonna get a discount
uh for your baby that means that you're
gonna have one less fee on you
then your main priority right now is to
pay your bills
okay it's to pay your bills your next
priority
is to make sure you cash flow the rest
of your college experience
so this way you can get into your
teacher job now here's one thing i want
to
just kind of recommend figure out a way
on how maybe on the side
you can generate a little bit more money
because making twelve hundred dollars
yeah i have been doing that this month
has been a little bit rocky
but last month i actually crochet on the
side okay
okay so last month was really good
because of christmas right yeah
yeah yeah so i'm pretty sure you made
actually you know a good grand or two
extra last years i mean last month
um so long as you're doing that jenny
that that's perfectly fine how old are
you
21 21. okay wow you're getting it so hey
and
and know this there there may be seasons
it's going to feel like either or in
some of these moments there may be
seasons where
you are going to buckle down with a just
with a like a specific goal in mind i'm
gonna take this job to pay this thing
off
and exhale that means i'm not gonna be
able to see my baby as much
and it's gonna be for this this series
this this season or
you're gonna flip that around and say i
don't these moments are finite i don't
want to
i don't want to um put my kid in take
here i'm willing to go six more months
i'm willing to go another year on
paying my debt off so that i don't have
to that's
sort of what i was struggling with
here's the thing they feel either or
like you're gonna do this thing forever
or that thing forever
think more seasonally think more right
now i'm gonna get
my last two years and get this degree
paid off i'm gonna
hustle it up i'm gonna get a full-time
gig
and i'm gonna put baby in daycare for 24
months and that's going to be that
or i'm going to like anthony said i'm
going to
crush it i'm going to work alongside
baby we're gonna
beans and rice beans and rice for
another year a little bit longer than we
were going to
but i'm gonna cash flow that degree i'm
gonna get in the door get a much much
higher paying job
that's gonna pay for my master's degree
then i'm gonna be a school counselor
and now you're off and running right so
think seasonally not this is the way
this is always going to be
because that's a trap that that young
moms fall into and there's
everyone around you wants you to feel
guilty about the decisions that you're
making
make sure you get somebody that you can
make those decisions with
think seasonally be at peace with your
decision and then like anthony said go
get it man
go get it and here's one last thing to
jenny i want you to
follow me on my youtube channel as soon
as you hang up i want you to go to
youtube.com
and i want you to to subscribe to king
coleman show
and subscribe to the table with anthony
o'neil just type those two in
and i want you to subscribe because um
i'm going to show you how to get the
mindset to keep pushing
and to get over the obstacles and really
how to build and get out of your debt
pay off all your debt and how to really
start building without that
at a young age in your bracket king
coleman is going to show you
how to get the shovel bigger so when you
come over to me we can do a lot of those
different things together so follow
those two youtube channels today
and i promise you you will be successful
but stay on the line kel's gonna get
some information from you
we're going to send you ken coleman's
book the proximity principle
um okay and then also go ahead and give
her a copy of destroy your student loan
debt as well kelly
just so she can have that so when she
does get to the point of paying off her
student loans
she already knows how to do it you know
one of the things i'm always telling
young people
uh john is you really have to step back
and really start identifying your why
and and i've been i've been repeating
this because i keep hearing
young people just you know they're not
as motivated you know they're not as
excited that they don't really have
the drive and i think they don't have
the drive because they don't understand
why they're working for what they're
working for
and when i hear young people like her my
son
will be my would would be my wife my
children
will be my wife my wife will be my why
because i want so much more for them you
know when i think about my kids
i don't want them to experience sleeping
in the back of the car for six months
i don't want them to experience not
being able to travel
and go to disney world when they're 12
years old
i want them to experience some
foundation but also experience
life and you know what else anthony i
want your why to also
be you yes because you've got value yes
you are worth not being shackled you are
worth
getting to sit back on christmas you are
worth hugging that kid
sleeping a full night's sleep yes you
know what i mean i like that
you're worth it too man yeah america i'm
going to repeat after us
you are worth it say it again
you are worth it i love it
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we have like uh
12 more minutes with you beautiful
people here in america
but before we get back to the phone
calls we have a beautiful scripture and
quote that we want to
leave with you all today today scripture
is from proverbs 15
22-24 says without counsel plans fail
but with many advisors they succeed to
make an apt answer is a joy to a man and
a word in season
how good it is the path of life leaves
leads upward for the prudent that he may
turn away
from the shoal beneath and phil jackson
says
the strength of a team is each
individual member
and the strength of each member is the
team
wow i love me some phil jackson he
is the best that has ever done it
nicholas is with us in british columbia
i love it
nicholas good afternoon how can dr dana
serve
hey how's it going thanks for taking my
call yeah man thank you so much for
calling in how can we help bro
so um my situation is i'm 24 years old
and i'm looking to buy my first
home or i guess it's really expensive up
here so i'm looking more like an
apartment
okay and i have a
pretty decent amount saved up right now
but i have my parents have done pretty
well as well and
they're trying to insist to help me out
with the down payment so i'm just
wondering if that would be
like something wrong to do not at all i
mean
i plan on buying my kids first house so
i mean i would be offended if my child
told me no i don't i don't want you to
help
or sow a seed into my my life let me ask
you a question because i want to be fair
in understanding to you why do you have
some questions about it
what's going through your heart and
through your mind
because i just um like i'm just thinking
for
their sake like i think because i'm
still pretty young i'm i'm 24 years old
and i
i should be able to buy a place within
the next year or two anyways
so i'm just thinking that they can keep
like more so they can keep their money
for retirement and that
like that sort of thing you know what i
mean okay so you have a good heart
you know you you love your parents yeah
and and i love that
um do you have any debt right now
nicholas
know that no yeah man i me personally
i'll let
dr dr john come in here and and give you
some wisdom but
um anytime your parents want to be a
blessing do it and
learn from your parents how are you
positioning yourself to be a blessing to
your kids in the future
and we start passing that down in the
family hey my mom and dad help me
i'm gonna help you and because i helped
you i'm gonna position you in a better
place
where maybe you could do more for your
child maybe you can buy their first
house you know that's my goal
bro is is my goal is that if i have
three kids when they get married
i can buy their first house now it will
be up to a certain budget amount
uh but that's that's my goal because i
want to sow a seed into my kids future
and pray that they will do it to their
kids and their kids and now
i've created a new chain a new kind of
family history
and a new family tradition within my
family but john do you see anything here
i'm missing i say nicholas i want to
give my kids a high five when they get
married
so that's that's what i'm hoping hey the
only the only thing
that i would be weary of here is
if you know that there's gonna be
strings attached
either explicit ones or implicit ones
if you know that mom's going to help
with that down payment and that means
she's going to want a key to the house
and she's going to come over every
weekend and check to see if it's clean
and she's going to be over there nagging
you if somebody or dad's going to be
in your business and really it's going
to be kind of his house where his son's
just living it
then yeah i would i would pump the
brakes on accepting money
if your parents just want to bless you
man they just want to take care of you
then i understand i put my pride in a
box
i would accept their gift and just
consider yourself blessed and like
anthony said make sure you
are living a life so that you can
steward that forward to somebody else
someday
absolutely man such a great question man
thank you so much for calling in
uh flint is with us and not flint i'm
sorry
edward is with us in flint michigan uh
good afternoon edward how can
dr d and i help hey thanks for taking my
call you guys
yeah um my question is i'm 45 years old
we're getting ready to
do the 15 in the 401k okay obviously we
stopped it to do
to get to this point but i got in a
traditional 401k i got 107 000
and i'm starting to roth from scratch
and it scares me
because i feel like at my age at 45
i should be dumping money into the 107
so it grows
but starting off at zero kind of scares
me i just i need some reassurance on
what i'm doing
yeah man i totally understand that
edward i would definitely sit down and
talk to a
one of our smart investor pros because
i'm asking i'm trying to figure out how
can i move that 107
and go ahead and put into a roth now you
will have to pay some some stuff there
on that part
but i will kind of weigh your options so
how can we move that over to the roth
account
because that's what i did here at ramsey
solutions um and then that way i'm
growing this money
tax-free okay so i want you to take
advantage of the roth program
i don't want you to keep putting money
into the traditional because you're not
growing it tax-free
and i want you to take advantage of this
especially at your age right now so
without getting too too um detailed
because you are at a season of your life
to where we need to make sure we're
making
all the right decisions i want to
connect you with our smart investor pros
so
have you met with any of our smart
investor pros yet
no i have not yeah because i and my my
company matt still goes into a
traditional so i'm going to have to
leave that open
well but you don't have to leave the
traditional open zero
no you're going to eat okay no so what
you're going to you're going to invest
into the roth
all companies are going to invest into
into traditional we do that here at
ramsey solutions
then at the end of the year i can say
yes move
my match over to my roth okay and so you
won't have to leave
that one per se particularly open you
can move that money over
but we need to see if that's even a wise
thing for you to do at this age and with
that amount of money
and what would that cost be so that's
why i really want you to particularly
sit down with a smart investor pro
that can look into how are you investing
it what's going on
um and make the right decision for you
and yourself
but i'm telling you right now you need
to take advantage of the roth
and we need to start putting money into
that but let's figure out how do we
what's the best way to get that 107
turned over there um
and edward just so you know brother um i
just sat down with a smart investor pro
to talk about how i'm going to split
mine between a roth and the traditional
how i'm going to go down those same
paths if i'm even eligible for a roth
what can i do on the back to all those
kind of things
i just did that exact same thing yeah
and i'm a few years younger than you but
um i'm weary of giving like anthony of a
particular
it's gonna it's gonna there's so many
different aspects that's why sitting
down with the smart investor pro is
gonna know what your goals are what your
risk tolerance is how much money you
make how much money your wife makes how
long you're going to make that money
all that goes into a pot and it's easy
just to say this versus that
sit down with somebody who's going to
walk you through and get exactly what
you're looking for
absolutely real quickly cola's in north
carolina talk to us real quick you got
30 seconds how can we help
hey gentlemen great to be on with you
yeah um my wife and i are babysit number
seven
i'm in the military um contribute about
22
of my base pay um to retirement okay and
um the money that we have left over
we're trying to purchase a home in cash
within the next 10 years
um and i'm kind of struggling with
whether we should be
um trying to max out our roth iras or
trying to
max out that house fund what's the best
way going forward how old are you alex
i'm 29 years old yeah max it out max out
your um saving for a house fund i'm fine
with that because you're already maxing
out your
retirement with um over here in this
area okay
so if you can if you want to go ahead
and start
just pushing it hard pushing it hard i
would try and cut that 10 years down to
maybe like
six seven and then from there if you
don't have a hundred percent
maybe you put down seventy five percent
and finance to twenty five percent for
like ten
seven years and pay it off quick i don't
want you to go 10 years without
investing into a roth ira
but you're already doing good investment
on this side with your company
um but i would definitely say yes if
your goal is to get in the house you're
debt free got a fully funded emergency
fund you're already investing into a
retirement account
and it sounds like you're doing it very
very very well 22 is high we only say 15
so i would even go down to 15 and then
from there you'll be good at gravy man
uh but i like the fact of a young person
talking about paying cash for a house
that's awesome man
what yep man you got me excited
cole you got me excited brother that's
how i like to end the show
okay yes we need more people calling in
calling in like that on dave ramsey show
madison i want to thank our producer
james shout our associate producer and
phone screener kelly daniel
and i want to thank the number one um i
call him counselor
the one and only dr john did only for
joining me on the show today it's always
an honor to be with him it's always an
honor to talk to you america
now don't forget the caliber of your
future will be determining the choices
you make you made the right choice today
by listening to the dave ramsey show
with
dr john deloney and myself anthony
[Music]
[Music]
you